so if this proves to be true and the
administration takes this action
what would the reaction be likely in the
FX markets well I think David what we've
seen is if you recall a couple of weeks
ago President Trump's new national trade
council head Peter Navarro singled out
Germany as somebody who's benefiting
from a grossly undervalued currency
so this multi-pronged sort of
multilateral approach to trade issues
has kind of already started and what we
saw that day was the Euro actually rose
now it's falling back since then on
political concerns David but I think
what it does is it takes some of the
sting out of the bilateral negotiations
between China and the US and perhaps by
widening the net
president Trump and the administration
are able to deal with other trade issues
with other countries and Germany being a
specific example that they highlighted a
couple of weeks ago and Richard when
Peter Oro made those remarks one of the
first questions was okay fine what is
the president going to do about it this
would be a suggestion would it not then
actually the president might be able to
do something about it
well yeah and the big thing I think that
is a that is raising concerns among
investors is if we do get more of a
protectionist bent from the
administration this will prove as a drag
on global growth David and if that's the
case I think it'll make the the
macroeconomic picture in 2017 and beyond
even more cloudy than it already is but
there is a distinction to be made again
between taking president Trump seriously
versus literally so are we to take a
potential tax of imports from countries
that they think potentially devalue
their currency at literal or is this a
suggestion and saying guys get it
together have a stronger currency and
I'll get off your back well I think in
the case of Europe and Germany
specifically Alex it's a pretty
complicated thing because of course
you've got many countries in the euro
area and one currency in one central
bank so I'm not sure how it you know in
the case of Europe specifically how
they're going to get their act together
because monetary policy is set for the
entire area and I think people have been
right to sort of look at Germany and say
they've been the big beneficiary of this
monetary policy even in Germany some of
the politicians are saying look we want
higher
we don't want the euro to be this week
but realistically with it with one
monetary policy for the entire continent
it becomes a tricky thing so I think
investors kind of have to take him
literally until we actually see the
details of what the plan is well I'll
give you that when it comes to Europe
but now when it comes to China I mean
China has been trying to actually prop
up its currency and prevent that
devaluation is this really just a
message to China
keep propping up your currency or make
direct investments here into the US I
think it could very well be that Alex
and and and the thing is it's very much
the relationship between China in the
u.s. is a very complicated one because
of course China is one of the biggest
providers of credit one of the biggest
buyers of Treasury securities out there
so when you've got your creditor dealing
with you and bolado trade negotiations
it does become quite complicated but I
think that that could be the message
that the Trump administration is trying
to send to China so looking down the
road just a little bit Richard I've
always heard it said that you don't pull
out a gun unless you really to fire it
once you start saying we're willing to
do this
does this really ramp up the possibility
of trade wars if they actually took this
action to impose countervailing duties
what would likely be the retaliation
from other countries well I think if the
first few weeks of the Trump presidency
has taught us anything is that is that
the president is not afraid to act and
and this could very much lead to you
know drawing the gun with the intention
of using it now what does it mean in
terms of the reaction from other
countries well China I think is already
starting to buy less Treasury securities
than they did if they were to continue
that and ramped that up that could be a
problem as US yields would rise perhaps
a little bit more quickly than anybody
is sort of planning on right now